this is princess day and boy did I think
this is gonna be a lot funnier with a
title like princess day maths there's a
lot of options there even the settings
really good yeah like the breakfast
Kingdom like that's like my probably my
favorite Kingdom out of all the places
they've made and it still what's amazing
like even a little car they drive is
amazing hey I'll loose what well then
interestingly the lights the headlights
were like olives all right I don't think
of those as much breakfast to you
there's somebody that has a way all
right so the the setup is all the
princesses are meeting by the way we had
a bet I thought there's gonna be a
character named princess day which would
have been awesome Ellie to be the set up
but they all need for princess day just
to go over I guess princessy stuff like
they all need something from the other
princesses and stuff I guess so yeah
princesses well they have their own
Kingdom yeah yeah actually you one makes
perfect sense except for LSP who
apparently doesn't have her own Kingdom
we've really confused me because doesn't
she know she ran away from home yes also
oh oh that's why okay yeah cuz I'll say
like wait she came from that can we've
seen that Kingdom but because you run
ran away doesn't get anymore okay and
Marceline is also they would surely
threw me for a loop but then I realized
I guess she kind of is yes their dad's
like the Lord of Darkness which I not
technically King but whatever they call
her the vampire queen yeah yeah so I
don't even more confusing well okay let
me just bring up major flaw really quick
she's out in the Sun throughout a lot of
this episode which even when she gets
teleported in from somewhere else she
was still in a lot of covering to stop
from bursting
to flames this one they were driving the
entire time in the Sun uh-huh and even
her hair was up in a pond yeah you can't
think of any way around that yeah I was
waiting for it to be like an a dream LSP
was having like me cuz remember she's
sitting there going oh yeah it was all a
dream
but maybe it's Dottie that's a great oh
maybe in this next episode I'll reveal
it but yeah you're right I didn't even
pick up on that you're absolutely right
oh I was actually getting another fan of
LSP and I was already getting frustrated
with the episode its episodes incredibly
mean-spirited but then when they go
outside and everything I'm like normally
they're very careful yeah they're
usually rounds half of that but this one
I mean if she was putting on some cream
or something like that and yeah
something even put a hat on you know
it's like big I don't know yeah god
that's I didn't even think that it's a
great point but but so LSP is sort of
seen as not being a real princess cuz
you ran away so
Marceline's bored so they going to start
making trouble because I guess they just
don't like the other princesses and
that's pretty much it and it's got a
Thelma and Louise
vibe because yeah that hasn't been
parodied yet you know those 20 year old
movies really fella Louise okay I mean
if it lets a great jokes whatever but
yeah they're just doing mean stuff it's
you know and usually with Adventure Time
they do the mean stuff okay but yeah it
was just like they just sort of pushed
people under be like oh ha ha ha ha kick
up literally kick up while they're down
they hit one with a car tell her to you
know dig I guess a sand castle which is
similar to digging a grade they just
leave her there
yeah and then they crash the car again
cementing that Elma Louise because the
car is going off the cliff and then the
toaster strudel princess our little
speech gets an egg lay down there is
this best princess day ever and that was
it uh yeah I just I was waiting for it
to build us something cuz it even starts
off mean-spirited like with them all
yelling at you know LSB which is like
okay she's sort of making a big deal
anyway but it's like they're all being
really mean to her you know I mean like
especially mean though I mean you don't
even have a home you have a law we leave
no I you're here it's like it's really
hard I felt in the beginning I thought
when LSP and Marcy first started off
doing their crappy things at first I was
kind of like hmm uh-huh because I really
felt the vibe coming from breakfast
princess was one of those bitches even
the way high school yes even the way she
talked and oh my god you just don't
belong here like that sort of valley
girl type I don't know just your
stereotypical Mean Girls yes
and so at first I was like yeah okay
this kind of makes sense whatever and
but it it just went so wrong that you
ended up feeling awful for everything
that happened when at first I was like
yeah yeah cut up there you know they
were horrible they were mean whatever
but it even when breakfast princess was
being mean it felt like okay it's just
your stereotypical whatever meanness
will go somewhere with this something's
gonna happen yeah like I was building
out there something but it didn't it
built up to this horribleness and in
even at Marcy's worst in the beginning
when she you know she was this badass
queen or whatever vampire queen and you
know they were scared of her when Jake
was scared of her even then she wasn't
that means she liked people to think she
was that mean but she really wasn't and
actually LSP was even worse than her
because Marceline was more or less kind
of like pushing the buttons and Jed she
was texting
peoples that you know I'm gonna see how
far this can go and all that stuff it
really wasn't even Marci being that bad
of a person it was more Allis P being
bad and Martin and Marceline going keep
going I mean what's the point of that
scene of the texting to them just the
choker phones are grabbing the phones
are cool by me and it was the whole high
school Mean Girls take piano days yeah
but there isn't a car Louise so yeah
yeah yeah I think this episode had no
idea what it wanted to do there's
episodes and I'm not saying every
Adventure Time episode does this I'm not
saying everyone should there was nothing
to be learned or gained from this
episode like I was expecting maybe
breakfast princess to be like okay sorry
LSP for me being kind of a jerk to you
you may not live in your kingdom but I
you still are a princess or something
and maybe learn a lesson to not be such
a bitch
but in the end she throws down the
shovel and just walks back it's like
okay nothing is learning well any values
being Marcy don't are LSB LOC and Marcy
they don't even learn anything did we do
bad things back there yeah but you know
whatever
yeah like even that's not really real
Marcy even says well no I don't think
we're bad people I mean you know bad
people do bad things and is that bad
well I mean you know not if you just do
it once cuz it's just and they like
totally like gloss over the whole thing
like this whole even though it was
horrible and mean-spirited like nobody's
business it's okay cuz it's the first
time we did it like that you know and
it's just like oh I feel bad about you
know taking the CD well mail it back
like that's not the point that's not
even the point well and there are there
are episodes where a little something
they can't mail back to CD I was still
in the car when it did the groundwork so
even that can't happen sorry exactly but
if there are episodes they've had where
they either haven't had a moral or have
even made fun of the fact that there's
no yeah or me there's gonna be moral and
not deliver it so I mean that's really
nothing new but they've usually had some
sort of really enjoyable funny extreme
and with these extremes like if you're
gonna do it it's like they don't even go
far enough and they don't feel just
fighter or comedic Lee justified you
know we've seen episodes where like Jake
seems a little too mean or Finn seems a
little to me because they weren't
justified and it's kind of the same
thing here where it just does not yeah
it's like breakfast breakfast princess
seems kind of like a jerk you know in
the intro but yeah it just seemed like
all I think of when I think this episode
is them hurting someone and they have
the mean eyebrows going ha ha ha like
that's all they think of what I think
this episode what and the worst joke to
me that I thought I don't know was when
they were being chased by one of the
maple guys and they put the holes in and
he goes and first of all he doesn't just
fall out they push him the hell out and
you see him fall and I wasn't like it
hurts yes I was waiting for the bottle
to shatter frankly and I was like oh no
and then they're just like and it pauses
and they're like great he's alive and it
was like and I guess that was supposed
to be the joke and I was like that is so
not even funny at all like that's a
horrible even one breakfast princess
gets hit by the car it's like the
violence in this seems surprisingly a
little too real yeah it's like what you
get it by the car it's like a real thud
down and stuff and when yeah when they
poked some on the eye they're like
really crying and they're really yeah
and it's just all the pain looks like
they're really feeling it but not it's
not a cartoon extreme way where like
they smash them or they do something
really comedic cuz a it's not justified
B it's not over the top it's done way
too real yeah yeah the lemon people were
arguably in worst conditions and yet
that was done in a way that you didn't
cringe you're like oh that's crazy
creepy and stuff but you didn't cringe
this it was like oh Jesus Christ yeah
because it's pushing it to an extreme
you know can't exist just cuz these
characters obviously these syrup people
can't exist yeah still the way they're
being treated like I said it you know
poking them in the eye and pushing on
and like you say when they when he falls
it's like you feel that fall and it's
not it's not fun because you just feel
bad for these poor people that have done
nothing wrong they seem like nice people
yeah you know yeah and we're
or just being you know just needlessly
mean and like I said it's I've seen
stuff before where people are needlessly
mean and it's funny yeah but yeah it has
to be justified it has to be just that
right balance and yeah this one both
doesn't go far enough and goes a little
too far somehow you know yeah like so
the violence is a little too real it's
not extreme enough you know so to a
point where you can laugh at it and you
know that would never happen and the
same thing with the situation where you
say that would never happen cuz you're
right it's like something out of high
school yeah you know where that happens
it it's kind of the same thing where
it's like if you just imagine this
happening in a high school as opposed to
the land of you or whatever it's like
would would you be laughing yeah I mean
it's like probably not yeah you know so
I do want to bring this up you were
saying you know
breakfast princess was kind of being a
jerk and all that stuff but let's toss
this into the mix
LSP was not invited and she was making a
rock yes she was eating the food she
crashed the party she's the one that got
up in the middle of yeah I was okay one
great joke raggedy princess do we can
see voodoo princess before because I saw
her I'm like mama is that character but
no no that one's a skull no no the hand
oh yeah I don't know - oh yeah I like to
be his princess yes but it's okay so
yeah I thought that was funny what the
sucks but LSP is there and she starts
doing what she normally does turning all
the attention on her wanting to make a
huge ruckus wants to be annoying and all
of her is annoying and so she's like
we'll wait what the hell are you even
doing here
if you were invited it was a mistake you
know and she was being bitchy don't get
me wrong but Alice P wasn't even
supposed to be there yeah it's like so
it's not even that yeah but on top of
that she was starting the ruckus - it's
a she's gonna crash the party that's one
thing but she is literally saying look
at me stomping everything and yeah and
then she's leaving it's just it's like
yeah you can see breakfast princess yeah
she's being a bitch or a jerk or
whatever but at the same time imagine
having a party someone showing up to it
that was not a
and then that person literally causing a
ruckus and saying pay attention to me
screw all you well I would just I mean
it's one thing to say please leave you
weren't invited please leave it's
another thing you know to again and not
to say that LSP is blameless cuz
obviously she's the worst - but it's
another thing to humiliate someone like
that I mean it's just mean-spirited to
humiliate it's something to say you know
what you weren't invited I don't
understand why you're here please leave
as opposed to you don't belong here
you're not even a real princess and you
have a shitty house and you have a
shitty buh-buh-buh let's just agree they
were all three of them were breakfast
princess LSP and Marceline the other
ones were kind of finding morals and all
that stuff I love PB come on let's get
out here yeah I'd like to but I'm really
invested in this crossword yeah I love
that um yeah I think the last thing cuz
my head is that like I said I mean we've
seen stuff like Looney Tunes don't
really just do mean-spirited things but
there's a charm there's a wit and
there's a way to identify with them that
yeah I I don't think is in this one I
never did anything that smart or funny
even and even if you're not gonna do
something where it's like they're
obviously stupid be funny and how stupid
they are yeah you know we don't even
really get that we just sort of get
harsh meanness so it's been done before
on the show and like I said this one
seems to be like they didn't know what
they were going for or I don't know and
like I said usually this show is spot-on
with like continuity and and all of that
stuff stuff and catching errors but this
entire episode like I said has to be a
dream or something
Marceline was out of the Sun no problems
yes and that's a huge flaw for a show
that usually really good what's special
about that you're right because they
like even like it's a even in the the
teleporting of the flash bang whatever
even then she's covered and there's like
such you know smart attention to detail
um and there's times where they drop the
ball on
my wife couldn't shake turn into
whatever but if that is such an obvious
one I mean that is just if this happened
you know if Sun hits her she burns I
mean just boom there's no like she
didn't think of a way out of it
hey I could've thought the way out of it
it's just sun hits her she burns you
know it's just as straightforward as
that know if it was sound like going
from building to building or something
like that where it's like okay tuck tuck
tuck tuck tight in another building yeah
okay whatever no biggie they didn't
catch it whatever but this was like an
entire like half of the thing where
they're running around outside yeah I'm
the whole last part of it was them
outside in the Sun and it's like only at
that system all right thanks I guess
there were clouds but it's like there's
plenty of blue goes down it's sunny and
then it goes into the shade of the ya
know right there you know even the
excuse I couldn't yeah yeah that and
also I now want breakfast yes I could
die in that king bed Lee want breakfast
right now I'm not a huge candy person so
the Candy Kingdom I could live in no I
invest eggs bacon sausage and pancakes
oh my god oh my god let's get some oh
yeah right now we're just gonna go make
something so yeah